- It is nice to see you again!
- I know.
- [Kelly] I got to see you in your room
and I got to tell you I was
actually terrified that one time
you had to drive me around
and you said I handled it well.
- You played it so well I had no idea.
- -Kelly] That just means I'm a good liar.
- You had glasses on too,
- -Kelly] I did.
I had those, but yes.
- Yeah, yeah
- We look like babies.
- We are babies. That's like '03 I heard.
- [Kelly] I know, I don't even know
but I remember the hair,
it was definitely "My December" era.
(audience laughing)
Have ya'll met before?
- We have not.
- No.
- My pleasure.
- Yeah, my pleasure, yeah.
- I've seen him
- Have you seen Hamilton?
- I have, yeah
- Oh my Gosh! It was so good!
- I have, my wife's a big fan as well,
so are my children,
so even my oldest daughter's been.
- Wow!
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah, look at that.
- I appreciate that.
- I hope you didn't pay too much
for your ticket.
- We did, we were happy to.
(audience laughing)
I mean, it was so good!
- Um, okay, this is a serious question.
I love Talladega Nights (laughs)
- Who doesn't?
- [Kelly] I love that film.
Is it realistic?
Do not ruin my dreams.
Go.
- It is very close.
Of course Hollywood's embellished some,
but yeah, I mean,
if we can't laugh at ourself
as a sport, then we
shouldn't be out there.
But I think they hit on quite
a few things that really do exist
in the world of NASCAR racing,
I mean, we're rolling
billboard's out there
and just the play on all that
throughout the movie is fantastic.
- Yeah, I love when I
go to a NASCAR event,
I mean the people watching,
I love those people, those are my people.
- World-class.
- It's like those people are everybody,
it's like everyone is so comfortable
in their skin,
everybody is there for a party,
it's like a country fest.
- It is.
- It's amazing.
It's awesome, I love it.
Well after seven championships,
you decided to retire this season, why?
- You know, I'm just looking
for some balance,
this is my 30th year
as a pro race-car driver,
which is hard to say.
- Wow.
(audience cheering)
- Thank you!
- That's a big career.
- It's been an amazing run,
my 21st season in NASCAR
and then this year when it finishes up,
will be my 19th year
as the top-level driver, as a cup driver.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- So, it's ya know
I'm ready for some balance,
I'm not done working in racing,
I still have a lot of things
I want to accomplish
and really compete in some bucket-level
ya know, races and events
and kind of check those boxes,
but two young children,
wonderful wife, life,
all that stuff that,
I just wanna balance it out some.
- [Kelly]] There's so
many things you love to do
but at the same time
you don't wanna miss out on anything
especially when your kids are so young.
'Cause they wanna play with you right now,
they don't once they
are a teenager. (laughs)
(audience laughs)
- True, that's very true,
I had a moment last fall
where just something shifted in my head
and it's never been about statistics
for me,
and staying the course
would be for me to chase,
trying to win and eighth championship
more and more,
- Yeah.
And that's not what I'm about
and what I want to be about,
it's more about the journey
and the racing and the fun.
So, once that shift happened in my mind,
I've been able to let go
and I'm really excited to see
what 21 brings.
- [Kelly] That's so cool, man,
I'll tell you what,
you never know,
I never knew I'd have this show,
so you never know what your life has,
you might have one, next year so.
But you just had your final race
at your home track, right?
- Correct.
- Well how did you feel about that?
Was it kind of emotional?
- Yeah very, very.
Not only my home track,
but the place of my first win,
my family was up in the flag stand
waving the green flag,
they had me out in front
of the field leading everybody around
for this five-wide salute,
so highly emotional to say the least.
- Wow! That's so cool.
That's what I love about
that crowd too though.
Everybody is so supportive,
and there for everyone,
that's what I love about
that NAASCAR vibe, too.
- It is a big family.
Every time I've gone,
it's just a really big family, but
how does your wife handle
your dangerous career?
Because I know my brother-in-law
races ARA, and I'm just like, nah.
I was like, I don't, yeah.
- Yeah
You know, educating her has been key,
we've been together 18 years
and that was right after,
when we first started dating,
was right after
- It's a shame she's so ugly
(audience laughing)
It's a shame! (laughs)
- Dale Sr's tragic death happened
just after we started dating,
and she was able to learn
so much about crash dynamics
and the safety that followed
and then what I do to be
the more safe in the car,
that really educating her was
a big part of it all.
And then my daughter's now
at the age where they're asking
those questions so I'm needing
to educate them too.
- Are your daughter's like you?
Are they adrenaline junkies?
- They like to dabble, for sure.
- [Kelly] Yeah?
- Yeah, they're into it
- [Kelly] Like what kind of things?
- Ah we're in Colorado
a lot in the summer,
so we're obviously in
the winter too, skiing.
So skiing, hiking, mountain biking,
motocross riding,
I bought 'em some go-karts.
- Oh my gosh, they're so cool!
- Yeah, there's their go-kart's.
- Yes!
- Their little rippers.
Um, yeah, we have a lot of fun.
There we are on the bikes.
- Oh my gosh, that's adorable.
Is that your wife?
- It is.
She's on the left.
- Could she be any hotter?
(audience laughing)
Geez!
I'm like, leave some of it
- Oklahoma.
for the rest of us!
- She's from Oklahoma.
Oh, she's an Oklahoma girl?
- Yes.
Oh my gosh!
- Explains it all.
- She's like I got this.
Yeah.
It's like a Texas woman, all right.
Well what's the girliest thing you
have done with your girls?
Cause we have a lot of like,
are they called "girl daddy's?",
I think that's what the term is.
We've had a lot of them on this show
and I love that.
- I'm involved in all levels
of what goes on,
but I'm under a lot of pressure
to have my toenails and
fingernails painted.
(laughing)
A lot of pressure.
- They're wanting you to really
get into that?
- Yeah.
- I will be honest,
I've seen my husband paint
my daughter's toenails,
our eldest,
when we first got together,
and he does a really good job.
(audience laughing)
Like better than me.
- I've found out that I'm not bad
at braiding hair recently.
- He's good at that too.
Yeah, I don't know,
he had horses growing up,
so maybe cause he did
that with their mane?
I don't know.
- I'm terrible at it.
- Oh, I can braid,
I played sports, so.
- I'm really bad at the hair.
I'm good at like the pretending,
so like the tea parties,
and like when I'm cast,
sometimes I'm step-mother or I'm,
you know what I mean?
(laughing loudly)
I'm good at the pretending stuff, yeah,
but I'm not good at the hair braiding.
- How many kids do you have?
- Just one.
One little girl.
- How old?
- She'll be three.
- Three? Awesome. Congratulations.
- Actually isn't her birthday April 23rd?
- That's right.
- A day before mine.
- Get outta here!
- She's gonna be amazing.
- Taurus. Taurus woman.
- Yes! (laughing)
- You'll let me know what I'm in for?
Please tell me.
(audience laughing)
- You know what?
Buckle up! (laughing)
- Oh wow.
(audience laughing)
- We're sweet until we're not! (laughs)
So do you ever let people drive you?
This is always my thought
with people that are race-car drivers,
do you not like,
- No chance.
- No chance? (laughs)
- Yeah, no chance.
I mean, for one,
- Does your wife remember
how to drive? (laughs)
- She's the most cautious driver
which drives me crazy,
so no chance I'll let her drive.
But yeah, control freak,
I'll admit it
but the other thing that you're going
to find funny
is I get motion sickness really easily.
- So if you don't drive,
no, this happened to me
- It's awful.
when I was pregnant so I
was just vomiting all the time,
it was wonderful,
and I literally would not
let anyone drive
and they're like
"well what if you vomit at the wheel,"
I'm like, I got a bag
because if I'm in that seat,
I get so motion sickness.
- So bad, yeah.
But if you're in control,
you're not.
That's so true.
- Yep, if I'm driving the vehicle,
I'm fine,
now if you put me in a cab or something
in New York,
it's awful.
- Oh, all the turns
- Yes it's terrible
- Just all those roads
they're just like crazy.
- They're great drivers, by the way.
- And everybody's honking.
Do what?
- Those taxi drivers in New York
are some of the best drivers
I've ever seen.
- Yeah, but it doesn't matter
how good you are,
this, every five seconds is like
not what I wanna feel.
- Recipe for getting sick.
- Yes! I'm like okay maybe we
just like creep up on 'em,
maybe don't just try
and ride their behind.